embarking on a new relationship joe
biden promises to reset ties with the
middle east on his first tour as us
president so what can he achieve and
will he be held back by political
pressures at home this is inside story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm nastasia tay now the us is promising
a new era of engagement with the middle
east joe biden is making his first trip
to the region since becoming president
and he'll have many issues to deal with
over the next four days biden's first
stop is israel where he's meeting acting
prime minister yaya lapid and former
leader benjamin netanyahu he'll then
head to the occupied west bank to meet
palestinian authority president mahmoud
abbas biden is expected to face
questions about the killing of al
jazeera correspondent shireen abu aklee
who was a palestinian-american
the u.s state department found that
israeli gunfire likely killed the
journalist but couldn't definitively
conclude the bullet's origin
a group of democratic senators has
written an open letter saying the
investigation doesn't live up to the
administration's calls for an
independent and credible inquiry
greater peace
greater stability
greater connection it's critical it's
critical for i might add for all
the people of the region
which is why
we'll be we'll discuss
my continued support
even though i know it's not in the near
term a two-state solution
that remains in might be the best way to
ensure the future of equal measure of
freedom prosperity and democracy
for israelis and palestinians alike
well stephanie decker has more
the last time president joe biden was
here in the region was in 2010 in his
capacity as vice president trying to
revive talks between the israelis and
the palestinians but just hours after
landing here the israeli government
announced the construction of a thousand
six hundred new settler units here in
ramat [ __ ] according to reports it
left joe biden furious and publicly he
stated this was very much against what
was needed to rebuild trust
between the two sides well now he
returns as president and ramach lomo has
turned into a massive illegal settlement
now settlements have continued to expand
both here in the occupied west bank and
in occupied east jerusalem it's cited as
one of the main obstacles to peace by
the palestinians under the previous
trump administration this was never
criticized but under biden washington is
taking a stronger stance president biden
however comes here at a time of israeli
political turmoil he'll be meeting with
the interim prime minister yeah lapid
who could no longer be prime minister
following november's elections and he'll
also be meeting with opposition leader
benjamin netanyahu a man he's known for
a very long time
biden will also be meeting with the
palestinian president mahmoud abbas here
in bethlehem where it's impossible to
miss the war really the symbol of
israel's long-standing occupation and
efforts to restrict the freedom of
movement of the palestinian people but
the administration has made it clear
that this trip
is more about integrating israel into
the region rather than reviving
long-stalled peace talks
well afterwards joe biden will take an
unprecedented direct flight from israel
to saudi arabia to attend a regional
summit there
we were going to in fact make them pay
the price and make them in fact the
pariah that they are
that's what he said about the kingdom
during the 2020 presidential campaign
while talking about the murder of saudi
journalist tamar khashoggi but biden is
under pressure in the u.s to deal with
high oil prices he and saudi crown
prince mohammed bin salman will attend
that same summit in jeddah but the two
are not expected to hold a bilateral
meeting
other items on the agenda include the
iran nuclear deal biden says he will
continue pressuring tehran to return to
the 2015 agreement former president
donald trump you'll recall withdrew the
u.s from that accord in 2018.
in iraq and syria biden has approved the
use of military force to prevent the
resurgence of groups such as isil and to
respond to rocket attacks on u.s targets
and washington is also pushing for
negotiations to end the war in yemen
well let's bring in our guests in
arlington virginia we have khalid
al-ghindi he's the senior fellow at the
middle east institute and also the
author of blind spot america and the
palestinians from balfour to trump from
london we're joined by andreas krieg a
senior lecturer in defence studies at
king's college london and in birmingham
is scott lucas professor emeritus at
birmingham university and founder of ea
world view and news analysis website a
very warm welcome to you all thank you
for joining us gentlemen i want to start
with the timing of this now biden's last
trip to the region was what over 12
years ago as vice president and he's
obviously been president for what a year
and a half now it hasn't gone unnoticed
that it's taken some time for this trip
to take place now the administration
obviously says they have plenty of
reasons to be there but given the oil
price and the proximity of u.s midterms
i
would guess that regional allies aren't
under any illusions about the urgency of
this visit so let me start with you
andreas what's the u.s relationship like
now with its middle eastern allies i
know the word transactional has been
used to to describe that relationship of
late
well yes um i think the biggest problem
that the united states has at the moment
is that it's too much preoccupied by
domestic polarization it's uh kind of
almost paralyzed by what's going in
washington the six of uh january
committee
a lot of pressure also on on biden to
deliver he hasn't really delivered on
much you know the amer america is an
unprecedented crisis domestically and
now his this trip to the middle east is
obviously coming against this backdrop
so he's kind of trying to show that uh
you know he wants to have a foreign
policy success he wants to show that in
terms of energy policy uh energy
politics as well as supply chain uh
security he's actually someone who's
getting things done but he has very
little to show for for what he's
actually been promising and it's also
kind of doubtful that he's that we he
will be able to actually show anything
uh in terms of success uh on on the on
this very particular trip so uh biden is
very much uh with a back against the
wall we've got midterm elections as you
were already saying uh and uh so people
are looking at him and saying what is he
actually what does does he have to show
for himself and he's leaving he's
entering into a region that and that's
not just the biden problem that for
three consecutive presidents it has
actually been left to his own devices
and where vacuums have been filled by
local players and by extra regional
players such as russia and china as as
competitors of the united states so the
united states is coming as a superpower
to the region but and no longer really
is received on the ground and perceived
on the ground as a real superpower
because it's really uh very impotent now
a very different middle east from
biden's last trip now he started his
trip in israel and his last visit
obviously wasn't uncontroversial scott
what do you think tel aviv is hoping to
get out of this visit might the actual
visit the presidential visit of someone
like joe biden busier lapids profile
ahead of the november elections there
well i mean certainly yar lapid and
indeed any israeli politician will try
to get some type of mileage
for domestic reasons ahead of the
elections provided being seen with biden
isn't too toxic but no the overriding
israeli concerns are
let's keep the focus on iran and who
needs to talk about palestine and by
that i mean of course that there are no
serious israeli-palestinian negotiations
there haven't been any of substance
since 2014 and i would argue there
haven't been any significant
israeli-palestinian negotiations since
2009 the first year when joe biden was
was vice president and israel doesn't
want that to change
israel wants to maintain its autonomy
including over the occupied territories
they made a token gesture
just today saying all right we'll delay
not
cancel but delay the building of some
settlements in the in the west bank but
pretty much israel has the upper hand in
palestine and no arab state but along
the united states is going to challenge
that at this point
and of course what does israel really
want to talk about they want to talk
about this this block to contain iran
some would argue push iran back and that
of course is a block which has really
been forged with the us in a sense off
to the side with arab states such as
saudi arabia and the uae i want to get
to some of those regional dynamics in a
minute but i do also want to talk about
the peace process between israel and
palestine the so-called peace process
the administration the bible
administration says it's still working
towards that now khalid i know you
yourself have been involved in previous
talks between the palestinians and the
israelis now given the current situation
and the u.s response to the killing of
al jazeera journalist srina
how are the palestinians actually
viewing joe biden as the president at
the moment
well first of all i i think there's a
deep sense of disappointment in the
biden administration um on the part of
certainly the palestinian
leadership but but much more so the
palestinian people although
expectations were already pretty low uh
on that front as far as the leadership
is concerned um they were hoping for a
much more proactive and engaged
administration after four years of trump
that had really set back american
palestinian relations uh to an
unprecedented low
and
so far
most of the trump legacy remains intact
with the exception of uh you know
opening direct ties with the palestinian
leadership restarting some aid to the
palestinians which is something the
administration frequently
likes to play up
um but other than that uh the bulk of
the trump legacy on jerusalem on the u.s
consulate
in jerusalem on
the closure of the plo mission and
frankly even on settlements
things like
the uh uh
former secretary of state uh mike
pompeo's policies to legitimize
settlements to treat products made in
israeli settlements as made in israel
to do away with the term occupied
territories these are doing away with
the legal memo on the illegality of
israeli settlements all of these things
are still on the books and i think
palestinians are kind of scratching
their heads and saying
why haven't these policies been reversed
well let me bring andreas in here
andreas khalid's been saying it seems
that the biden administration has
largely embraced a lot of the trump era
policies so was that a considered
decision on the part of that
administration or has biden just been
distracted by a whole load of other
issues
well yes he has been distracted but i
would say this administration is very
clueless when it comes to foreign
security policy more widely but
particularly on the middle east he ha it
hasn't delivered he's written an op-ed
in the washington post this week or last
week
where it becomes quite clear that there
isn't a strategy there isn't a vision
there isn't something that america can
actually deliver and and the problem is
there's a growing say do gap
and what i mean by that is what america
preaches and what it actually does is is
becoming ever more overtly uh
you know
that becomes an ever growing discrepancy
between these two things and i think
what we what we see particularly in the
issue of palestine is that there hasn't
been a reversal on on on any of the
trump policies there is actually a
continuation of a path that has been
going you know has been set for decades
already and all we see is that
presidents like obama or trump or biden
they might have put an added different
nuance to it but at least donald trump
was someone who was kind of as
destructive as he was he was very
overtly destructive that you knew what
you were getting with biden there's a
lot of ambiguity about on the on one
hand saying we are interested in
engaging with the palestinians we're
interested in engaging with iran but
when it comes to actually doing
something about it uh you know real
polity is hitting and that same is true
for saudi arabia a lot of narrative
about human rights conditionalities but
when it comes to actually delivering on
it there is a continuation of the status
quo that is is you know a very very much
uh very very puzzling for for both sides
of the divide in the middle east iran
doesn't know what to expect the saudis
don't know what to expect uae don't know
what to expect israel doesn't know what
to expect and that sort of creates this
ambiguity and a state of of leaderless
uh uh chaos in the region uh which other
people you know have been willing to
fill other nations have been willing to
fill uh iran was able to act on as as
they see fit uae is acting as they see
fit we've got russia and china moving in
where the americans have withdrawn the
problem is what does america actually
want and that's the question the
administration hasn't answered in the
same way that the previous two
presidents haven't answered that
question either well i'm interested in
how u.s politics actually
relates to the region and how regional
leaders are viewing the u.s because i
see biden's approval rating at home is
what now just 33 percent and a majority
of democratic voters are saying that he
should not be on the ballot in 2024. so
now given the possible change of
administration um in not too long scott
how do you think regional leaders are
actually viewing biden
well i've got a lot of contacts in saudi
arabia who from day one of the biden
administration simply scoffed at biden
and his advisors um they
had very bad relationship with biden and
the obama administration and they
expected this to carry on
they see the binding administration as
being too weak on iran
they see biden as being too weak in
general and the israelis similarly
although biden talks a lot about the
primacy of israel in the relationship
they don't necessarily see biden as a
strong leader especially in the context
of where the us is with a divided
domestic scene
but i i think and i agree with a lot of
what andrea says but let me have one
point just for discussion where i do
disagree with him a bit
i i don't think biden administration are
clueless here
i think they know what is going on in
the middle east but i think
they
realize they don't have leverage and by
that i mean
a few years ago after jamal hassoji was
assassinated probably on the orders of
mohammed bin salman
there was leverage the turks wanted
something to be done other countries
were appalled by what was happening and
you could have acted them of course
donald trump didn't
move forward to 2022
and the fact is is that well three
things why the us doesn't have leverage
first of all it has been outflanked by
the maneuvers between israel and the
arab states
secondly uh it faces
as long as it puts its priority on
containing iran and doesn't reach a
settlement with iran over the nuclear
program then saudi arabia has leverage
on that issue
and thirdly
is the question of the oil supply in the
context of russia's invasion of ukraine
in a conflict which is likely to be
protracted
so if your opponents have leverage not
your opponents if your interlocutors
have leverage like the saudis and the
israelis
you don't go in to antagonize them biden
in other words is playing on the
defensive not because he's clueless but
simply because american power is not
exactly very powerful in the current
context of regional politics well one of
the things that biden has really come
under fire for at home in the u.s is
this next stop on his trip is saudi
arabia khaled you're sitting in the u.s
now at a very tricky time for biden how
are u.s voters viewing this whole trip
well it's it's interesting because
actually the polls show
even though usually the public is public
opinion is pretty disengaged from
foreign policy
um and they but they generally like
presidents to to sort of lead on foreign
policy matters
the the polls currently that i've seen
are showing uh quite a lot of
disapproval for this trip i think part
of that the problem is
most americans like i think many
analysts in washington and elsewhere
and diplomats and others don't really
understand the purpose of this of this
trip is it a photo op uh is it really is
it about oil prices the administration
uh keeps telling us that it's not is it
about domestic politics sort of
posturing uh with israel
ahead of a midterm election
and using israel to market its
uh
the administration's
ties to saudi arabia as a way maybe to
blunt criticism
you know your guess is as good as mine
uh the american public simply doesn't
understand
uh i mean first of all they don't really
care about foreign policy even though
foreign policy
uh directly affects their lives uh just
have a look of course at uh at oil
prices and gas prices
um the administration has not done a
good job of explaining the linkage
between these foreign
uh crises and
the situation back at home and i think
as a result
most americans just don't understand and
as a result uh end up kind of
disapproving well as you say that the
white house has been dismissing
criticism of biden's trip to saudi
arabia here's what national security
adviser jake sullivan had to say about
that when it comes right down to it
isn't this trip proof that strategic
interests including oil and gas when it
comes right down to it are always going
to override something like human rights
america's values human rights are a
strategic interest of the united states
so is energy security so is stopping
terrorism so is seeking peace in a place
like yemen so we are trying to do
multiple things all at once advance
along a number of different tracks one
of those tracks is in fact ending the
blank check policy and as i said before
the basic thrust and purpose of our
policy with respect to saudi arabia has
been to recalibrate the relationship but
not rupture it we have stayed true to
that from the beginning of this
administration andreas recalibrate not
rupture is that code for we need help
with the oil price
well yes this is code but i agree with
what was said previously there is no
evidence whatsoever that this trip is
going to make a difference on the oil
price on inflation uh you know we know
that the saudis and the emiratis
actually have reached somewhat the end
of the line when it comes to their
capacity they will not want to buy in
into their into their into their into
their reserve capacity at this point and
even if they did the millions of barrels
that they could bring online per day
will not make a huge difference to bring
down the oil price at the pump so all of
that is kind of window dressing um i
understand that obviously supply chains
need to be need to be uh taken care of
and obviously there is a huge concern
that there is this pivot of the uae and
saudi arabia towards russia and china
particularly because there are oil and
energy and interdependencies growing as
the oil and energy and the dependencies
with america are actually going down uh
but at the same time this trip will not
do very much in that respect i think
what this is about is more about
security it's about creating a new
alliance and i think the rapprochement
that we will and i say rap rush more
rather than normalization but there will
be a rush more announced between saudi
arabia and israel on some strategic
matters and i think that's going to be
the kind of foreign policy win that
biden is looking for but you know as the
previous speaker said the issue here is
everyone is scratching their head about
why is he doing this what is he what is
there to win for the biden
administration because everyone will
look right through it i mean
recalibrating this relationship at for
what benefit it benefits the saudis
benefits the israelis but what does it
really do for the biden administration
you talk about building this alliance
and i want to take a bit of a broader
view here because this is all taking
place within the context of a war that's
raging on in ukraine now the u.s has
obviously made no secret of trying to
create a global coalition to counter
russian aggression there so
i was interested looking at some opinion
polls in the middle east though it it
seems that many more people and many
more countries are more anti-american
than they are pro-ukraine scott how much
support is biden actually likely to get
for that agenda
well i'm not sure if biden will get a
great show of support from the middle
east but
the purpose of this trip is to keep
arab countries from going to the other
side just as the us did in its approach
to india
where it was worried that india would
become too supportive of russia indeed
almost back the invasion and work for
months to prevent that happening
part of this trip here is to try to
limit uh the development of ties which
andreas has written about
you know between russia and saudi arabia
over energy indeed you had a russian
envoy who just recently was in saudi
arabia so i i think from the standpoint
of realpolitik and and look human rights
are expendable here ideals are
expendable here the idea here is to make
sure not only saudi arabia not only the
ua but indeed the entire gulf area
at least stays neutral in this conflict
and indeed begins as it were in quiet
ways to sort of support the ongoing
international coalition to push back on
the russian invasion so i suspect in
september because it's being leaked from
both sides both from
the saudi side in the u.s side the
saudis will increase oil production in
september how much of that will buffer
the domestic situation in the united
states and help fight before november's
election i don't know but the increase
in oil production by the saudis will
send a message which is we're not
dependent on russia we're not being held
hostage by russia and that's a pretty
important message at what may be a
turning point in the ukraine conflict
with kiev beginning to score some
success in the battlefield i was
interested to see that jake sullivan
who's biden's national security adviser
he also very recently revealed that
intelligence agencies have decided that
iran was planning to aid russia in its
battle against ukraine
how might that shape conversations in
the coming days especially given the
state of the talks around the iran
nuclear deal
well obviously iran is going to be a big
focus of this trip both in israel and in
saudi arabia
so there's there's no question about
that
whether
uh whether that means there's going to
be some progress at some point uh on the
iran nuclear deal that remains to be
seen so far we haven't seen that so
again i think this sort of plays into
this
this question about
uh that that most people have about what
is this trip really about um but if i
could just sort of go back to the the
point that was raised earlier about
about human rights
um
i agree with the the uh i think it was
andreas who said the
uh there's there's this huge gap between
what the administration says and does
and i think
that is uh nowhere more evident than in
this rhetoric about about human rights
and frankly whether we're talking about
israel or saudi arabia the both of their
records on human rights are are quite
abysmal
and we're seeing uh the administration
really give a pass
not just to those two uh regimes but
also others that will be attending uh
the the summit in in saudi arabia for
example like egypt or jordan
egypt has an especially egregious record
on human rights there is a growing sense
that this administration
is really uh prepared to i think trade
away human rights
uh uh and and democracy
in a way that even the biden
administration was uh didn't go as far
uh
yeah because i i do want to give andreas
a very quick last word because i'm
curious in one sentence andreas what
would you say a successful trip would
look like
there is no successful trip um because i
i would absolutely agree with everything
that's been said at this point is that
there this trip is going to be defined
by a weak president in the weak united
states that is unable to leverage
whatever leverage they've left
and the seiju gap is just widening and
it leaves a credibility gap as well that
are very easily be defined and and
filled by the russians and the chinese
who do authoritarian stability much
better than the americans so uh at least
they're very upfront and very direct
about what they're doing we'll see how
it all plays out in the coming days well
in the meantime though thank you to all
of our guests carla del gindy andreas
krieg and scott lucas and thank you two
for watching remember you can see this
program again anytime by visiting our
website that's aljazeera.com and for
further discussion do go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
aj inside story and you can also always
join the conversation on twitter our
handle is at aj inside story for me
nostalgia and the whole team here in
doha bye for now
[Music]
you